-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The White House today announced
plans to form a task force
to combat online harassment.
Go to their website to check out
the announcement,
but heads up --
do NOT read the comments.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci
tested positive yesterday
for a breakthrough case
of the coronavirus.
Wow! Fauci is like
COVID's final boss.
This is...
This is like hearing that the
Coyote caught the Roadrunner.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you caught it now?
You made it through
all that time
in the maskless
Trump White House,
and you caught it now?
That's like running a triathlon
with no problems
and then throwing your back out
petting a dog.
[ Laughter ]
Florida yesterday
became the only state
to skip pre-ordering doses
of the coronavirus vaccine
for young children.
To be fair, Florida
doesn't have children.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in New York
this week
seized more than a dozen
Weed World Candies trucks
because some owed
more than half a million dollars
in parking tickets,
Said the drivers,
"Parking?"
[ Laughter ]
"We thought we were speeding."
Organizers of a British
music festival announced
that rapper Lil Wayne
will no longer perform
after he was denied entry
into the UK
because on his health form
screening,
he put down
that he was wheezy.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's not great,
but it tracks.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, producers
of the upcoming Barbie movie
released a picture yesterday
of actor Ryan Gosling as Ken
with bleached blond hair
and six-pack abs.
And in an homage
to the original toy,
his head was facing
the wrong way.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!